ام
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم ابدى المؤتمر
الوطني العام في ليبيا قبوله المبدا بال
مسوده الرابعه التي تقدمت بها بعثه الامم
المتحده خلال جوله الحوار الاخيره في
المغرب بشرط تضمينها الاعتراف بحكم
المحكمه العليا بحل مجلس النواب نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقشه في المحورين
ما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله لموقف المؤتمر
الوطني الاخير من مسوده الاتفاق الرابعه
وما مصير الحوار بين اطراف الازمه الليبيه
في ظل مواقفهم الراهنه من مقترحات الحاله
ام ام اعراض عبر عنها مبعوث الامم المتحده
الى ليبيا بان ارتين ولان في احداث اختراق
مهم فى الازمه الليبيه قبل حلول شهر رمضان
وفي سبيل تحقق هذا الامال هذه الامال على
الارض دفع المبعوث الاممي بمسوده الحوار
الرابعه انها تكون على الاقل اساسا لاتفاق
يريح الليبيين من ازمه كانت كا وكادت تعصف
ببلادهم انتصر الامور في الاتجاه الذي
اراده ليون بعد رفض مجلس النواب المنحل
مسودته للحوار لكن تغيرا ما حدث من جانب
المؤتمر الوطني العام الذي قابل المسوده
ولكن بشروط تقرير فتح
مزيد من الانفراج في حوار الفرقاء
الليبيين بعد الزخم الذي ربما تكون قد
اضافته اجتماعات العاصمه الالمانيه كما
وعد سابقا كشف المؤتمر الوطني العام في
طرابلس عن موقفه من بات يعرف ب مسوده
الاتفاق التي قدمها المبعوث الدولي
برناردينو ليون ل طرفي الازمه خلال اخر
جلسه مباحثات في الصخيرات المغربيه
المؤتمر ابدى قبولا مبدئيا بالمسوده لكنه
اشترط اجراء تعديلات عليها تتضمن بالخصوص
الاعتراف بحكم الدائره الدستوريه في
المحكمه العليا في ليبيا بحل مجلس النواب
اي ما يعرف في برلمان الطرق في شهر نوفمبر
الماضي ومن ضمن التعديلات ايضا الطالبه
المؤتمر بتشكيل لجنه لصياغه التعديلات
النهائيه المطلوبه ومن ثم رفعها الى
البعثه الامميه في غضون ايام لا يعرف ما
اذا كانت تلك المطالب تلقى قبولا مليون او
منو فقط برك لكن المؤكد هو ان المسوده لم
تكن في صيغتها النهائيه او جاهزه للتوقيع
بل كانت من المرونه بحيث تحتمل المراجعات
والتعديلات والاقتراحات من في الحوار وكان
برلمان الطرق المنحل قد طلب من وفده
المفاوض في المغرب وقف الحوار والعوده
فورا قبل ان يقرر بعض اعضائه الذهاب الى
برلين مع وفد المؤتمر الوطني والمبعوث
الدولي للتباحث مع وزراء اوروبيين وممثل
للدول الخمس دائمه العضويه في مجلس الامن
ولعل ذلك ما انعكس تهدئه في الاجواء بعد
ما اوشكت مفاوضات المغرب على الوصول الى
افق مسدود
ويعزو مراقبون تشدد موقف وفد تبرز رغم ان
معظم بنود مسوده الاتفاق تعتبر لصالحه الى
ان المسوده تدعو الى تكوين جيش وطني
الليبي وتعيين قائد اركان بالتوافق وهو ما
يلغي عمليا حظوظ اللواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر
الطامح الى لعب ادوار عسكريه وحتى سياسيه
كبرى في ليبيا ومن الواضح ان الوقت ينفذ
امام مساعي التسويه مما يعني اطاله امد
صراع اثبتت الايام والوقائع ان لا منتصر
فيه وان كلفته تتعاظم على الليبيين في كل
مناحي الحياه
وحده تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
المتمدد يبدو المستفيده من تبعثر اوراق
الحل في ليبيا فهل يساعد توسعه شرقا وغربا
على تضييق فجوه الخلاف بين المتصارعين
باعتبار انهم مستهدفون جميعا
موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع ضيفينا من
طرابلس نعيم الحالي عضو الفريق الاستشاري
للجنه الحوار بالمؤتمر الوطنى الليبى
العام ومن باريس ينضم الينا كامل المعاش
الكاتب الصحفي الليبي ابدا معك السيده
نعيمه في انتظار ان يجهز اه ضيفنا من
باريس يعني في الواقع هناك من يرى ان لا
تغير حقيقي في موقف المؤتمر الوطني الليبي
العام من مسوده اتفاق اه ليون بتنازلات
الحقيقيه التي قدمت من قبل المؤتمر الوطني
اه بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله بدايه تحيه لقناه الجزيره والعاملين
بها والمشاهدين اليها اه موقف المؤتمر
الوطنيه العام واضح كيف كيف هذه ال لا
تكون هناك موقف مغير اه نرى الموقف
المؤتمر منها المسوده الثالثه كيف جاء
الرفض منذ اللحظه الاولى شكلا ومضمونا في
حينما تعامل المؤتمر مع هذه ال المسوده
بكل موضوعيه وبكل اه واقعيه اه راي اه
ابدا الموافقه المبدئيه عليها شريطه بعض
ال التعديلات في بعض المواد الذي يراها
المؤتمر اه من صميم المهمه ان تكون داخل
هذه المسوده لذلك اه يكون اكبر دليل على
تعامل ال المتغير لموقف المؤتمر الوطني مع
ال المسوده اه لكن ما معنى ان اه يبدي
موافقه مبدئيه حينما يطالب بضروره اعتماد
قرار المحكمه العليا بحل مجلس النواب وهو
ضمنيا نزع الشرعيه عن هذا المجلس
والقبول بالحوار مع يعني على اي اساس
تتفاوضون هم
ربما بايه صفه هم ايضا س يفاوضون كم
اه منذ اللحظه الاولى طبعا عندما وافق
المؤتمر الوطني على ال على ال اه الحوار
وكانت له الضوابط التي اعلن عنها منذ
الجلسه الاولى هي احدى الاحترام الاعلان
الدستورى و حكم القضاء واهداف 17 فبراير
هذه الضوابط الذي لن يتنازل عنها المؤتمر
الى هذه اللحظه رايناها اه انعكاساتها
داخل هذه المسوده حيث يحاول السيد اليوم
ان يوافق ما بين احترامه لحكم المحكمه في
وجود المؤتمر واحترامه ل صندوق الاقتراع
وال الناخب اللي ب في وجود مجلس النواب
وعلى ذلك اشتغل المؤتمر اه لا لا محال ولا
ضروره اه ولا مهرب من ان يكون الحل السلمي
داخل ليبيا عن طريق الحوار لذلك وافق
الجلوس مع ال مع مجلس النواب في حين اكد
على ان يكون ايضا الجلوس المباشر للوصول
الى الحل الحقيقي ورفض المجلس النواب الى
هذا الجلوس المباشر مما وصلنا الى مسودات
الرابع كان بالامكان ان تكون من المسوده
الاولى اه تم وانجزنا اه م ما بيننا من
خلاف ووصلنا بليبيا الى الحل لهذه الازمه
اه لاحظناها ايضا وتمنينا ايضا في جلسه في
لقاء برلين طالبنا ايضا باللقاء المباشر
جلسه واحده مباشره لوضع الاتفاق ووضعت ال
الضمانات ايضا لهذا ال الاتفاق ولكن ايضا
اه تعنت مجلس النواب وعدم الجلوس المباشر
او اه الى هذه اللحظه ولكن اه المؤتمر ما
يراه اه قضاء حكم المحكمه بحل اه مجلس
النواب اه
اه ضروره نحن نقول تنازل اه ضروري من
التنازلات الى حد ما ولكن ما معنى التنازل
انه هو ضياع هذا اه حكم من المحكمه اه
بالعكس حكم المحكمه لا زال قائما يتمثل في
اليه في طريقه ما تكون من خلال التعديلات
في بعض المواد التي جاءت في هذه الم ال
المسوده ما يتمشى مع حكم المحكمه لذلك لكن
لكن العامه المؤتمر على واقعيه هذا الطلب
وبالتالي ما امكانيه قبول الطرف الاخر به
اصلا
واقعيه هذا الطرف عندما السيد ليون يحترم
هذا الحكم اه بطريقته
المحكمه
السيد ليون نحن نحاور الموقف الطرف الاخر
لكن ا وجها الى وجه على طاوله واحده ولكن
هي في الحقيقه نحن نحاور السيد ليون من
خلال جلسات الصغيرات وجلست استخدام س
الاولى الطرف الاخر لو اراد الحوار معه
لكن اجل سمعنا اذا الحوار مع السيد ليون
نحن علينا المؤتمر الوطني نعمل كل اه ما
لدينا من وطنيه واقعيه بان نصل بهذه
المسوده الى الى الحل ولكن الان يبقى دور
السيد ليون مع الطرف الاخر اذا اذا اذا
رفض او اذا عمل اي ما يقف اه اه في طريق
هذه المسوده في ذلك دورها وهو وهي الحقيقه
اليوم وليس مجلس النواب
من الواضح كما يرى الكثير من المراقبين
بان هناك عقدت ان اثنتان اه هما الان
تقفان امام الجلوس اصلا على اي طاوله
للحوار بينكم وبين اه وفدت برق وهما
الشرعيه المتعلقه بالشارع او المتعلقه ب
اه الجيش من سقف التنازلات التي يمكن
فعليا ان يقدم عليها المؤتمر الوطني
الليبي بخصوص هاتين النقطتين او العقدتين
اذا قلنا ال الشرعيه او الوقوف عند
الشرعيه هي السبب في عدم ال الجلوس مباشره
المؤتمر الوطني رغم حكم المحكمه الدستوريه
بليبيا بان ال المؤتمر الوطني هو الجسم
التشريعي ولكن مع ذلك اه قبل بالجلوس مع
مجلس ال النواب
اذن المؤتمر لم يضع الشرعيه هي الحاجز
والحاقدون الجلوس المباشر اه بناء الجيش
ال الجهه ال اه طبعا ال الامنيه في البلاد
وهذا الحقيقه نحن نرى ضروره اعاده بناء
الجيش من او من من الاول كل من يحمل رتبه
ويحمل رقم تحت جيش وطني حقيقي ينتمي الى
حكومه والى رئاسه اركان حقيقيه في في
اعاده بناء الجيش على الطرف الاخر لا
يختلف حول هذا الموضوع لكن هناك اه علامات
استفهام اه ربما على تشكيلات معينه هناك
رفض يعني صريح لبعض التشكيلات ان تكون
جزءا من اه هذا الجيش كيف يمكن باعتقاد
التجاوز هذه النقطه
ال الترتيبات الامنيه التي جاءت مرفق الى
هذه المسوده واضحه جدا مع هناك فيها اه
قراءات كثيره وهناك فيها بعض النقاط التي
تحتاج الى نقاش واعاده النظر فيها ولكن
الجيش الليبى الذى اسسه مجلس النواب طرق
بقياده المتقاعد خليفه حفتر لا اعتقد ان
يكون في يوم من ايام هذا هو الجيش الحقيقي
نحن نريد جيشا يضم كل من يحمل رتبه عسكريه
اه فجر ليبيا ايضا يضم اه تحتها الكثير من
الكتائب ومن القاضي هذه هذا فجر ليبيا
وهذه الكتائب هي خرجت للدفاع عن دورتها
هناك كانت ثوره مضاده وخرجت للدفاع عن
دورتها عن هذه ال الثوره اذن نحن الليبيون
جميعا مؤتمر وشعبا وحكومه نحتاج الى جيش
جديد يبني من الاول جيش حقيقي فاعل قوي
على هذه الارض يعني الانسان ربما كيف
السبيل الى ذلك من الخطوات العمليه الان
في ظل اه ربما غياب لغه الحوار بين مختلف
الاطراف خاصه مع كل التحديات والاخطار
المحدقه اه بليبيا
اه نحن المؤتمر الوطني نعمل جاهدين على
الوصول بهذه المسوده الى بر الامان والى
الاتفاق اذا تمت هذه المسوده وخرجت وتم
الوصول الى التوافق على حكومه وفاق وطني
واه وما جاء في هذه ال ال مسوده هذه
الحكومه واليه تشكيل الجيش والان المسوده
طبعا نصت على احاله اختصاص القائد الاعلى
للجيش للمجلس ال المجلس الرئاسي فاعتقد اه
بوجود المجتمع الدولي برعايه اه اه هذه
البعثه اي مخاطر او كل ما يهدد بناء هذا
الجيش فهنا دور ال البعثه والمجتمع الدولي
لل للوقوف بجديه حقيقيه ان كان بالفعل
المجتمع الدولي يسعى الى بناء جيش يضمن
حمايه هذا الشعب حدوده وثرواته واه ارضه
اه ب بات دائما معنا الان ضيفنا الكريم
السيد كامل للمراه ش الكاتب الصحفي من
باريس سيد كامل نامل ان تكون قد صنعت على
الاقل جزء من النقاش الذي دار بيننا ومع
اه السيده نعيمه مجمل ما ذكرت بان هناك
بالفعل حسن وهي من قبل المؤتمر الوطنى
الليبى الذى قبل بهذه المسوده مسوده
الاتفاق مبدئيا على الاقل رغم التحفظات
والملاحظات على بعض من اجزائها لكن الطرف
الاخر في المقابل
وراء رفض كامل وصريح لهذه المسوده يعني
الم يكن ربما من الاجدى الموافقه بالشروط
التي يراها هو
نعم دعيني في البدايه اه وهناك م كل
الشعوب الاسلاميه بمناسبه شهر رمضان
المبارك الذي اه اود ان يكون شهر خير
وسلام وهدوء في ليبيا اه ثانيا اه اه هناك
بعض الملاحظات على التقرير الذي قدمته
الجزيره وانا اعتبر ذلك
حيزا كبيرا
وفيه كثير من عدم المهنيه ثالثا انا
استمعت الى الحوار الذي
اه ضيفتك من طرابلس واه المس فيه نوع من
التغيير في لهجه المؤتمر الوطني
انها ربما على طرفي نقيض من افكارك لكن
تقرير الجزيره نؤكد على التزامنا
بالمصطلحات المستخدمه من قبل المجتمع
الدولي في توصيف الاطراف كما هو في توصيف
الوضع مثلما وتفضل ان
لا لا اه اه التقرير به اخطاء كبيره يقول
ال ال البرلمان المنحل والمجتمع الدولي
يقول البرلمان الشرعي الذي يعترف به كل
العالم والذي نتج عن صندوق الاقتراع
طبعا ونستفيد من
النقاش تفضل السيد كان
اه اه الحديث جميل يعني في طرابلس وانا اه
خرجت على العديد من الفضائيات مع بعض اه
من اه محسوبون على المؤتمر الوطني وعلى اه
حزب الاخوان المسلمين وكل هم يتكلمون حديث
طيب لكن ما يجري على الارض في طرابلس في
الحقيقه اه عكس ذلك تماما مازال هناك
تحشيد عسكري ما زال هناك تطرف في طرابلس
ما زالت هناك تشكيل جبهه صمود ما زالت
طبول الحرب تقرع واه اه وهذا يتزامن مع
شهر رمضان المبارك يعني اه العام الماضي
شهد هذا الشهر الكريم حرق مقدرات الشعب
الليبي حرق المطار الهجوم على
على الارض
يعني الموضوع
نعم
نعم انا اخشى انه الحديث النعم الذي يؤديه
بعض افراد المؤتمر الوطني العام لا يتناغم
مع ما يجري على الارض في طرابلس يجب تجنيد
طرابلس حرب واه حرب كسر عظم يعني هذا هو
الاساسي المسوده التي قدمها السيد ليون هي
اه تصلح لان تكون اه اه اه القاعده او
مبدا لاتفاق سياسي لانه اه هي لم تقدم
اتفاق سياسي تحقيقه اه طويله تسعه وستين
ماده فيها معيبه
اخر
نعم نعم خلقت جسم جديد يكون فيه السيد
ليون اه
يقوم فيها السيد اليوم بدور بريمر العراق
وهذا شيء مرفوض يجب على الشعب الليبي ان
ينتبه الى هذه النقطه السيد ليون يريد ان
يكون هو المصارع في حلبه اه اه التيران
وله الكلمه العليا هذا الماخذ الاول
الماخذ الثاني هناك اختصاصات اصيله
تشريعيه
للبرلمان الشرعي وسحب جزء من هذه
الاختصاصات اه ربما يكون هناك التنازل في
هذه النقطه لكن اه اه التنازلات لا تغطي
بالجمله اه اه كيف يمكن قبول ان يكون
تسعين اه عضو من المجلس الاعلى للدوله من
المؤتمر الوطني العام لماذا لماذا يعطي
تسعين اه اه كرسي في هذا المجلس المستحدث
كنا نطمح ان تكون هناك وجوه جديده وجوه
الموجوده في المؤتمر الوطني العام هي من
اوصلت ليبيا الى هذا المازق وهي لا تستحق
ان تكون في هذا المجلس وبهذا العدد الكبير
المعطل الذي يعطل الحياه السياسيه والذي
يعطي ايضا اه حق الفيتو على بعض قرارات
وقوانين اه البرلمان الشرعي يمكن اه كل
هذا معالجته ويمكن التاسيس عليه والبرلمان
لم يرفض المسوده وانما طالب بوضع بعض
التعديلات عليها واضح تماما طبعا سنناقش
اه كل ما ذكرت هو اكثر الان اه نذهب الى
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده مصير هذا الحوار
الليبي في ضوء مواقف طرفي الازمه اه كما
تابعنا ها من مقترحات الحل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش ومستقبل الحوار بين طرفي الازمه
الليبيه في ضوء موقفيهما من مقترحات
الوسيط الاممي للحل نعود مره اخرى لطلب
سيد النعيمي مستقبل هذا الحوار كيف ترين
اه بعدما سمعته من ضيفنا الكريم من باريس
وبعد مختلف المواقف التي تتلمس سموها من
الطرف الاخر
اه بدايه يعني بس اصحح معلومه للسيد الضيف
اه حضرتك من باريس نعيمه الحامي لما دخلت
المؤتمر الوطني ادخلت عنا قائمه تحالف
القوى الوطنيه
ولكن كما تعلمون بعد حوالي اه قبل ان
تنتهي السنه تم اه حل هذه الكتله وانا كنت
مستقله عن الكتله هذه النهائيه النهائيه
وال وال وليس لها اي علاقه بحزب العداله
والبناء هذا اولا ثانيا
كفانا يعني اه بين اتهامات
التشكيلات المسلحه وان طرابلس
العكس بان طرابلس امنا وليس هذا
يعني الان موجود على الارض ولكن كلها
اتهامات باطله لها لكن انا اقول بالنسبه ل
مصير ال الحوار الان الحوار في ال مبعوث
الامم المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي هذا المجتمع من الذي
يراها ضيفك وغيره بانه هو الاهم في في في
الدوله الليبيه وفي السياده الليبيه حيث
يقول كيف نقبل الجسم اه لم يعترف به دوليا
ونرفض جسم هذا الجسم اعترف به القضاء
الليبي اذا كان لدينا قضاء ونحترم قضاءنا
ونحن مؤسساتنا داخل ليبيا كل من يحمل
الجنسيه الليبيه عليه باحترام مؤسساته
داخل اه ليبيا مصير ال الحوار اه اذا كان
انا من المؤتمر الوطني فاقول بان المؤتمر
مع انجاح هذا الحوار ولديه الى ربما
المقترحات وال وال اختيارات الاخرى ستعلن
في حينها ولم يدع هذا الحوار يفشل وكل
ملاحظاته ستكون موضوعيه وواقعيه مع
المسوده ونجاحها ولكن ما يقدمه الطرف
الاخر فعلا اه البحثه اتخاذ قرارها والزام
من يعرقل هذه المسيره بان
المواطن اللي في وقفها ليبيا وقفنا مما
يحدث لدينا ونرى ايضا ما يحدث على الارض
هذه الايام سيد كامل يعني هناك من يرى بان
ما يحدث على الارض يعني تمدد تنظيم الدوله
على الارض اه الليبيه اه ربما القلق
الدولي الذي بات متصاعدا التربيه حتى
بعقوبات من يعرقل هذا الحوار ناهيك عن
مئات الالاف من المهاجرين غير النظاميين
المتحيلين الفرصه في الشواطئ الليبيه كل
هذا ان لا يضغط بالفعل اه على كل دي بي ل
ان يجلس الى طاوله الحوار ويبدي ملاحظاته
ويعطي شروط من اجل المصلحه الليبيه في
نهايه الامر
نعم هذا صحيح تنظيم داعش لكن قبل ان نصل
الى اه اه توسع وتمدد تنظيم داعش
فلابد ان نسال السؤال من المسؤول عن تمدد
هذا التنظيم
الحقيقه لها بمقدمه لا لا لحظه لحظه لحظه
انا انا بس
قلت هذه المقدمه حتى يعرف المشاهد خلفيات
هذا الموضوع داعش لم تنزل لنا من السماء
ولم تدخل من الشباك هي دخلت من الابواب
ودخلت من المواليه الليبيه ومن المطارات
اللي بها
الحوار لان هذا هو صحيح لا لا طيب طيب طيب
والان انا اعرف انه جزء كبير من فجر ليبيا
اصبحوا يعون هذه المساله جيدا ويدركون هذا
الخطر وبالتالي هناك انقسام في طرابلس بين
جناح اه يريد التصالح ويريد المصالحه
وهناك جناح اخر متطرف لا يريد ان
يعني اود ان نعرف منك الحوار
نعم
نعم هناك ولكن هناك انقسامات ليس بالحد
الذي هو موجود
على الاقل في هذه المفاوضات
من يمثل هناك من
لا لا لا ليس هناك انسحابات وفد البرلمان
الشرعي مازال والسيد ليون ذهب الى القاهره
للقاء النواب للاستفسار على المسوده مازال
هناك بحث وكل التصريحات التي خرجت من
البرلمان الشرعي تقول هذه المسوده يمكن ان
يبنى عليها اتفاق هناك معيبه وهناك اه عده
ملاحظات عليها وسيقوم الرحمان
لكن ما يجري في طرابلس على الارض هو يؤكد
ان هناك انقسام كبير في طرابلس وما يجري
حول طلب الاستاذ
تغير المعادله العسكريه ايضا يضغط في
اتجاه المصالحه والاتجاه وواضح السيد كان
سيده نعم اذن انقسام كما يقول ضيفنا في
طرابلس وبالتالي سؤال ما الخطوه القادمه
التي لديكم اخوتكم في ثلاثين ثانيه لو
تكرمت
الخطه الان هناك لجنه بالامس صدر لها قرار
لتجميع ال الملاحظات
ستتحمل هذه الملاحظات لرئاسه المؤتمر
وستكون لنا جلسه لعرض هذه المقترحات
والاتفاق عليها وارسالها الى السيد اه
اليوم وننتظر السيد ليون اه ولكن لدينا اه
مقترح الثاني والثالث يعني في حينه ولكن
كل هذه المقترحات لدعم هذه هذا الحوار
وهذه الموجوده والخروج بليبيا الى بر
الامان اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيده نعيم
الحميد والفريق الاستشاري لجنه الحوار
بالمؤتمر الوطنى الليبى العام في اتمام
طرابلس اشكرك جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من باريس
كامل المراه الكاتب الصحفي الى
ختام حلقتنا السلام عليكم
ام